howard's daddy helped him get to the top
but you both had to struggle
howie has so much we have so little
let's take him down a peg or two
today's video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
who has a great deal going on that i'll
introduce at the end
this video will contain spoilers for
better call saul through season 6
episode 7 and the entire breaking bad
universe if you're not caught up then
this video won't be for you were caller
bars ever really popular they are
instantly recognizable but i can't
remember a time when they were something
that everyone had i do remember knit
ties having a time in the couple of
years i had to wear one for school but
even the fanciest of the second graders
didn't wear the bar hey guys pete here
today i want to talk about howard hamlin
a great character who was brought to
life through a wonderful performance by
patrick fabian howard isn't the type of
guy that i find terribly relatable but
the type of character i can really
appreciate he met a tragic end that he
definitely didn't deserve and in a world
where most characters take the dark path
he was one that went the other way
howard's been around since the beginning
but was somehow never the center of
attention we mostly saw the image he
projected to the world which was a big
part of his job and something he was
very good at and it wasn't until season
six that we saw some of the things that
he kept hidden he became a more complete
character when we learned about his
personal struggles we had been seeing
him dealing with the fallout of chuck's
death but that mostly felt like it was
to emphasize the fact that jimmy wasn't
doing the same a couple of short scenes
at the therapist's office and at home
with his wife went a long way to
humanize him and added sincerity to
things like the job offer early on he
was just an obstacle that was in jimmy's
way something he had to overcome a rich
prick whose daddy gave him his job and
whose most notable qualities were that
he had a winning smile and wore the
right suits one of my favorite
confrontations happened way back in the
first season after chuck tells jimmy
that howard doesn't think he should use
his own last name for his law practice
jimmy fights back which we understand
because it seems absurd and his plan
involves copying howard's look as if to
say look how easy it is to be you it's a
perfectly crafted situation where you
certainly root for jimmy who's the
underdog even if you don't quite
understand what he's trying to do
because howard's actions seem irrational
and petty later you find out that chuck
was the driving force behind most of it
but even then what does it say about
this guy if he just goes along with his
partner's crazy schemes against his own
brother his connection to chuck shapes
our feelings about howard because most
of the time he's reacting to things that
his mentor does one neat little trick
the writers did was to have both people
who are most affected by him enable
chuck in different ways based on what
they need from him and we will come back
to this in a little bit
in his final episode there's an amazing
scene where howard encounters one of his
new hires at hhm this guy is tasked with
restocking the refrigerator in the
conference room and gets startled by his
boss dropping some of the cans onto the
floor in just a few lines of dialogue
this scene reminds us of who howard was
and how he's changed over the course of
the six seasons we've spent with him the
new employee carrie is making an obvious
mistake and when howard points it out
you recognize the potential for him to
talk down to this guy in the process of
reprimanding him this is an important
day for the firm and howard was there
early giving the room a final check to
make sure everything goes according to
plan everyone who's ever been the carry
in this situation recognizes that if you
were chewed out by your boss here it
wouldn't feel out of the ordinary chalk
it up to his nerves or your bonehead
move and try to do better next time
that's not even taking into
consideration the stress we know he's
under with kim and jimmy plotting
against him on top of his troubles at
home with his wife
what's fascinating is that howard reacts
in a way that almost feels out of
character he just calmly shows carrie a
simple solution to his problem spin the
can on the table to use centrifugal
force to dissipate the bubbles and boom
no exploding soda there are a couple of
things that come to mind here one is
that he doesn't have such an elegant
solution for his own problems and two is
that he learned this one from chuck it's
a big surprise when carrie doesn't
recognize the m from hhm from the
painting and probably one of howard's
best moments happens when he starts
talking about him he refers to chuck as
the greatest legal mind he ever knew
when carrie responds that he hopes
someone says the same about him someday
he pauses briefly before saying well
maybe there are more important things
and this one exchange evokes howard's
entire journey in this story it also
makes you think about his legacy
considering that chuck is already being
forgotten it's the kind of moment that
starts to make you worry about a
character's future and i really like
that they opened this scene with him
moving the chair away from the table you
find out later that this is so he can
bring irene in in a wheelchair that she
doesn't need to make his side look more
sympathetic in the mediation it's almost
like the kind of things they've been
doing with howard's character for the
last couple of seasons and you can't
miss the fact that this looks like
something jimmy might do and it also
brings to mind when he was working with
chuck to convince mesa verde to leave
kim and stay with them he is a character
that's worked to improve himself but we
see that he has his flaws like the rest
of us this makes what happens to him all
the more difficult to watch against kim
and jimmy's plan the power dynamics
shift and that makes him a lot more
complicated and compelling and how else
would those actually shift if it wasn't
about them running a scam it's the one
arena where he can't compete and one
where kim thinks she can get what she
wants knowing howard will bounce back
like he always does because they were so
sure we know something had to go wrong
it didn't seem possible for him to
protect his legacy and because this is
the world where breaking bad takes place
you have to fear for his life we know no
character is safe in this universe but
if you want to stay safe on the internet
you should probably check out today's
sponsor surf shark
surfsharkvpn keeps your online identity
safe by encrypting all the information
sent between your device and the
internet this keeps your personal data
protected from big companies or cyber
criminals with surfsharkvpn you can
change your device's location and use
the internet from different countries
around the globe i use it all the time
to unlock geo-restricted content like
trailers and clips that aren't available
where i live you can also use it to
access shows or movies on netflix that
aren't available everywhere due to
licensing deals different libraries show
up when you view netflix in different
countries when i search for better call
saul in the us i have access to five
seasons but when i switch my location
with surf shark i can access all six
including the most recent episodes today
if you use my code pete peppers you can
get 83 off plus three extra months free
plus free antivirus you can try it out
with no risk since surf shark offers a
30 day money back guarantee they even
allow you to use your account across
unlimited devices so make sure you
follow the link in the description below
you can't dispute that howard changed
and improved himself when his back was
against the wall the changes that he's
made also work against him in the past
he had a connection with jimmy because
they had the loss of chuck in common
jimmy lost a brother and howard a mentor
friend and business partner hamlin dealt
with his grief and came out the other
side while jimmy didn't do anything so
by the end of season 5 when all of
jimmy's feelings came out in a meltdown
at the courthouse howard can pretty much
wash his hands of the situation he tried
to take the high road and offer him a
job at this point what more can he
really do he was on the receiving end of
a similar meltdown from kim as well when
he inadvertently pushed her buttons when
he tried to bring up jimmy's erratic
behavior in the final season he was in a
different place when they started to
come after him and there was nothing
stopping him from fighting back the fact
that he was outmatched and then also
really unfortunate in his timing set up
his tragic ending that is also much more
than that in relation to the story i
suppose when a character like this is
removed from the board i asked myself if
it seemed like it mattered and in this
case was it fitting since he obviously
didn't deserve what happened to him it
was shocking but it didn't feel like it
happened to produce a cheap shock so for
me it's a yes to both questions it
mattered because howard was a
complicated character that i felt
something about as he lost his life it
was fitting because he had been there to
contrast jimmy's transformation and died
because of the same decisions that
sealed his fate to become saul goodman
completely in some ways he was the last
connection to the jimmy mcgill story and
cutting that has a lasting effect on the
few remaining survivors it also clears
the way for them to move on to the next
phase of the story where the two shows
come together and the line between them
is blurred nacho's death was tragic but
he got to go out on his own terms for
something he believed was worth dying
for howard's death is tragic because he
really would have been okay if lalu
hadn't shown up at the apartment what
kim and jimmy did was cruel and
unnecessary but even after he said his
peace about what was wrong with that and
with them as human beings he
acknowledged that he would bounce back
everyone present knew that to be true
and that the plan was designed to come
out that way because he'll never be able
to do that this outcome will haunt jimmy
and kim from here on out
and it's not all bad because he did go
out with a hell of a monologue which is
a lot more than some of the characters
in this universe can say he got to ask
the questions the audience had been
thinking about and he got to make his
case against jimmy and kim from there we
get to sort out how we feel about it and
for me i just love that it's all so
complicated as i mentioned i never found
howard that relatable so i wasn't as
sucked into his sympathetic turn as some
fans but the way things played out felt
absolutely tragic i don't know that you
could say he was innocent but you could
argue that he was the last moral man
standing when you take that away it
changes the world that's left for
everyone else to inhabit i really
enjoyed the performance throughout and
the final monologue was the perfect way
to send off the character and i couldn't
help but feel real despair when lalo
entered that room the flickering candle
brought up a feeling that i didn't
realize i was harboring i think he was
mostly correct in his assessment of
their motivations and it was satisfying
to see him lay all of that out although
i think lolo was the only person in the
room that registers on the sociopath
scale that's not to say that kim and or
jimmy might not join him before it's all
said and done but their plan against
howard doesn't get them there for me by
his own admission he's lived through
worse his dying in spite of that might
make it hit harder than nacho's end in
his case even he recognized it had to
happen where with howard it just didn't
in both cases they're wonderful
characters that didn't necessarily start
out that way howard's last episode
revealed him to be much more complicated
than he seemed his death serves the plot
but his character leaves the impression
and he'll turn out to be a measure of
how we see jimmy and kim at the end of
the series so r.i.p howard hamlin sad to
see you go i think the fact that he'll
be remembered as a drug addict who
disappeared or killed himself is the
worst part of it all he couldn't protect
his reputation or legacy any more than
chuck could and that is pretty rough
everyone dies no one deserves to have it
happen this way and then to have the
good overshadowed and forgotten for
essentially nothing at the end of the
day you can like him or hate him but you
can't ignore the injustice in his ending
he could be the most sympathetic
character for you they certainly led us
in that direction maybe you're just like
him or your dad was like him or you're
just in the collar bars it doesn't
really matter because as far as i'm
concerned it's everything else that
makes howard so memorable and why his
ending hit so hard this is a show where
it feels like the creators and writers
put a lot of emphasis on the choices
characters make and the consequences
that come from those intended or not the
choices the writers made in developing
howard hamlin made all the difference
and that seems like a good place to
leave things let me know how you feel
about this character in the comments now
that you've had some time to process it
how do you feel about his ending and
what do you think that tells us about
where things will go from here please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon